ein virus auf dem vormarsch in den usa
infizieren sich immer schneller immer
mehr menschen mit corona haft strafen
für randalierer drei jahre nach dem
g20-gipfel in hamburg werden mehrere
angeklagte verurteilt und harte brocken
für deutschen teams dem fc bayern wenn
er denn weiterkommt und rb leipzig
drohen in der fußball-champions-league
unbequeme gegner
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg genannt und willkommen
zur freitagsausgabe der heute
-nachrichten norbert lehmann ist auch
dabei für den sport einen schönen und
dann doch familie warum wird
ausgerechnet in der größten
volkswirtschaft der welt die korona lage
immer schlimmer
us-chef immunologe fauci spricht von
einem albtraum und macht die zu frühen
lockerungen in einigen bundesstaaten
dafür verantwortlich anders als andere
industrienationen haben es die usa nicht
geschafft die kurve der neuansteckungen
nachhaltig abzuflachen im gegenteil seit
wochen geben die zahlen wieder deutlich
nach oben aktuell trauriger rekord mehr
als 63.000 neuinfektionen an einem tag
im ot wissen berichtet sie kämpfen um
jedes leben hier in houston um einen 66
jährigen patientin texas kalifornien
florida melden die höchsten todeszahlen
pro tag seit beginn der pandemie
obwohl die behandlungsmethoden viel
besser geworden sind das blut mit
sauerstoff aufladen hilft mit
beatmungsgeräten die luft hinein zu
pressen so doktor der wolke beschädigt
die lungen noch mehr aber wieder kaum zu
glauben nach sechs monaten krise fehlt
es an schutzkleidung auch das warten auf
einen test dauert viele stunden das
warten auf das ergebnis bis zu zehn tag
ein armutszeugnis meint joe biden sein
700 milliarden dollar wirtschaftsplan
soll auch sicherstellen dass amerika
alles selbst produziert was es in krisen
brauche ich wenn wir steuergelder
ausgeben dann sollten wir damit
amerikanische produkte kaufen um damit
amerikanische arbeitsplätze zu sichern
beiden kommt trump zuvor der seinen
wahlkampf mit dem slogan buy american
kauft amerikanisch produkte führen er
klaut halt gern ein sehr linksradikaler
planer hat zwar das richtige gesagt weil
er es von mir kopiert aber der
unterschied er kriegt das nicht hin
trump will dass alle schulen wieder
öffnen aber es gibt keinen abgestimmten
plan weder national noch regieren und
dann ist da noch die meldung dass sich
in den wenigen ferienlagern die es gab
viele kinder in
sie zierten durch schule öffnungen
könnte sich das virus noch schneller
verbreiten der präsident hat heute
öffentliche termine in florida trotz der
wohn ansteckungsraten dort wo das gäbe
ist die gar nicht wird morgen auch
amerikas größter vergnügungspark
disneyworld seine pforten wieder öffnen
in deutschland ist die lage viel
entspannter hier sinkt die zahl der
neuinfektionen weiter
im schnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
haben sich pro tag 380 menschen neu mit
dem virus angesteckt gestern lag die
zahl bei 400 angesichts der niedrigen
infektionszahlen könne man ja die masken
pflicht im handel abschaffen
diese idee kam vergangene woche aus
mecklenburg vorpommern wie der rest der
republik dazu steht zeigt heute das
politbarometer an seinem stern mit den
details die antivirus maske pflicht beim
einkaufen und das soll auch so bleiben
sagen die gesundheitsminister von bund
und ländern
und nicht nur die 87 prozent der
deutschen finden die masken pflicht in
den geschäften richtig skepsis also beim
thema lockerungen und durchaus auch
besorgnis beim thema reisen sommerurlaub
in der pandemie
69 prozent aller befragten fürchten hier
steigende infektionszahlen die korona
krise sie bleibt das große thema und sie
hat großen einfluss auf die
stimmungslage auch in sachen machtkampf
in der union bei der kanzlerfrage
mittlerweile deutlich in führung markus
söder
64 prozent der deutschen halten ihn für
geeignet csu chef markus söder kommt
bundesweit viel besser an als noch im
märz vor der pandemie wohl auch wegen
seiner als restriktiv und gradlinig
wahrgenommenen corona politik ohne
konflikt mit der kanzlerin
armin laschet dagegen ist es bisher
nicht gelungen sich als krisenmanager zu
profilieren
armin laschet einer der drei bewerber um
den cdu-vorsitz ihm trauen 19 prozent
die kanzlerschaft zu er liegt damit
hinter friedrich merz und vor dem
dritten kandidaten norbert röttgen alle
zahlen aus dem politbarometer gibt es im
heute journal um 10 und natürlich online
rezepte erfreute app unter anderem was
halten die deutschen von einer
wiedereinführung der wehrpflicht und von
fahrverboten für zu schnelle autofahrer
jetzt zum umstrittenen chinesischen
sicherheitsgesetz für hongkong seit es
erlassen wurde können chinesische
behörden hart gegen alle aktivitäten
vorgehen die aus ihrer sicht die
nationale sicherheit bedrohen das gesetz
wird scharf kritisiert nicht nur in
hongkong auch international in berlin
gab es heute im außenministerium ein
gespräch mit dem chinesischen
botschafter gunter lapp energy die
bundesregierung hat sich im gegensatz zu
anderen westlichen ländern wie
großbritannien oder usa bislang sehr
zurückgehalten mit kritik an china
wie ist jetzt dieses gespräch mit dem
botschafter zu beurteilen ja das
gespräch zeigt dass die zurückhaltung
noch nicht wirklich abgenommen hat denn
es ist ein baustein aus dem
diplomatischen baukasten de die
chinesische regierung zwar vermutlich
verärgern wird weil sie sehr auf
umgangsformen bedacht ist und auch eine
ein solches symbol sehr genau wahrnehmen
wird aber es ist eben auch keine härtere
maßnahmen kanada und australien zum
beispiel haben das auslieferungsabkommen
mit hongkong ausgesetzt angesichts der
jüngsten entwicklungen und ein ähnlicher
schritt ist von der bundesregierung noch
nicht in aussicht gestellt das
verhältnis zu peking ist für berlin
tatsächlich auch schwierig china ist in
den letzten jahren immer wieder größter
handelspartner deutschlands gewesen es
gibt viele deutsche unternehmen die
massiv investiert haben in china also da
gibt es eine gegenseitige abhängigkeit
und es ist auch bekannt dass angela
merkel immer darauf gesetzt hat
gesprächskanäle offen zu halten dass es
eben einfacher wenn man erst mal auf
milde maßnahmen setzt als auf eine
größere diplomatische oder andere keule
und deutschland ist auch gastgeber für
den eu china gipfel der vom september
verschoben worden ist sollte im
september stattfinden ist verschoben
worden
soll aber dieses jahr noch stattfinden
heißt es und auch da will man natürlich
die kanäle offenheit eine gemeinsame
europäische lösung wäre wahrscheinlich
das was der bundesregierung am ehesten
entgegen käme aber auch die ist momentan
noch nicht in aussicht
dankeschön nach berlin schock unterleib
energy
es ist fast auf den tag genau drei jahre
her dass die proteste gegen den
g-20-gipfel in hamburg völlig
eskalierten
unter anderem zogen rund 200
linksextreme vermummt über die
elbchaussee zündeten autos an und
beschädigten häuser und geschäfte heute
dazu das erste urteil drei jahre haft
für einen franzosen vier deutsche kamen
mit bewährung und geringeren strafen
davon
martinis die bilder gingen um die welt
220 schwarz gekleidete und vermummte
menschen zünden während des g20-gipfels
rund um die hamburger elbchaussee autos
an zerstörten schaufenster werfen
belohnt brandsätze ein von anfang an auf
einschüchterung angelegte aufmarsch so
das gericht
und das grundrecht der
versammlungsfreiheit fallen nur
friedliche versammlungen und da ist die
kammer davon ausgegangen und hat
festgestellt dass das hier nicht der
fall war
landfriedensbruch und beihilfe zur
brandstiftung die fünf angeklagten sind
schuldig die strafmaße sehr
unterschiedlich 120 arbeitsstunden für
zwei damals jugendliche täter mehr als
einjährige bewährungsstrafen für zwei
weitere und drei jahre haft für den
haupttäter
die staatsanwaltschaft hatte für alle
beklagten haftstrafen gefordert prüft
nun eine revision gehen davon aus dass
hier eine mittäterschaft liche
verurteilung hätte erfolgen müssen und
zufrieden auch verteidigung und
sympathisanten der angeklagten die auf
freisprüche gehofft hatten daran
teilgenommen haben
das gericht kritisierte indes die
politisch aufgeheizte stimmung während
des verfahrens die vorsitzende richterin
sagte dass gerade auch die
staatsanwaltschaft das verfahren
politisiert habe
von den rund 220 mutmaßlichen tätern
sind das die ersten die überhaupt
identifiziert und angeklagt wurden
bislang gibt es keine weitere anklage
das heutige urteil könnte also schon das
ende der juristischen aufarbeitung der
gewalt exzesse von der elbchaussee
bedeuten nach new york dort ringt der
un-sicherheitsrat in diesen minuten
weiter um die verlängerung der syrien
hilfe und damit auch um das schicksal
von millionen syrien die mitgliedsländer
streiten vor allem um zwei türkische
syrische grenze übergänge über die rund
2,8 millionen menschen in den
rebellengebieten lebensmittel und
medizin erhalten
die vetomacht russland fordert nur noch
einen übergang zu erlauben
das un mandat für die hilfslieferungen
in das bürgerkriegsland läuft in der
nacht aus johannes hano in new york
worum geht's hier eigentlich warum wird
da wegen zweier grenzübergänge
gestritten wer erstmal geht es darum wie
viele hilfsgüter syrien erreichen oder
die region idleb erreichen können
russland war immer gegen die einrichtung
von diesen hilfs korridoren und versucht
diesen prozess jetzt langsam zu
strangulieren ursprünglich waren dass
ihr mal vier das wurde dann auf druck
von russland im winter auf zwei
reduziert deutschland wollte das
fortsetzen das ist jetzt am veto
russlands gescheitert und man setzt
jetzt auf einen und das will die
mehrheit nicht das reicht nicht aus
warum sind die russen oder so
zurückhaltend eigentlich muss noch
menschlich klar sein dass diese hilfe
weitergehen muss russland verfolgt ein
strategisches ziel russland möchte dass
assad die komplette kontrolle über
syrien zurückgewinnt und das zynische
kalkül dabei ist ganz einfach je weniger
hilfslieferungen an kommen desto mehr
leiden die menschen und je mehr die
menschen leiden desto eher sind sie
bereit sich wieder in ersatz arme zu
werfen oder schlicht und einfach aus der
region zu fliehen
und das bedeutet dass das hat
möglicherweise sehr viel einfacher die
kontrolle über die region zurück
gewinnen könnte live aus new york
johannes hano vielen dank in polen
entscheidet übermorgen eine hoch
spannende stichwahl über die zukunft
unseres nachbarlandes entweder gewinnt
der herausforderer jobs kowski er steht
für ein liberales und europa
freundliches polen oder der
regierungstreue präsident du da wird im
amt bestätigt er wirft deutschen medien
vor sich in den wahlkampf einzumischen
aus warschau natalie steger in
siegerpose
aber er weiß es dürfte eine zitterpartie
für ihn werden die umfragen sehen duda
gleichauf mit dem gegenkandidaten du da
setzt auf sozialleistungen für die
traditionelle familie bloß keine homo
rechte und er kritisiert zuletzt die
berichterstattung der polnischen zeitung
fakt mit deutscher verlags beteiligen
will dieser konzern axel springer mit
deutscher abstammung dem die zeitung
fakt gehört die präsidentenwahl in polen
beeinflussen die deutschen wollen einen
präsidenten in polen wählen das ist eine
gemeinheit
das polnische außenministerium legt nach
und bestellt diese woche den
stellvertretenden deutschen botschafter
ein
wegen einiger artikel deutscher medien
du da braucht auch die wähler rechts von
der national-konservativen
regierungspartei und die dürften er und
die pis mit kritik an deutschland
durchaus mobilisieren konnte hinter
skurski der warschauer bürgermeister
seine schlagworte tolerant des polen
europafreundlich er will ein
gegengewicht werden zur peace regieren
alles ist in unseren händen es ist in
reichweite
entweder jetzt oder nie denn diese walte
der pis wird versuchen alles zu
überfahren
es geht um viel denn der präsident kann
mit seinem veto gesetzentwürfe auf eis
legen und das würde die
nationalkonservative regierung beim
umbau polens empfindlich treffen schauen
wir nach istanbul dort ist eine
umstrittene entscheidung gefallen
die hagia sophia kann wieder eine
moschee werden
das gebäude thront als wahrzeichen über
der stadt im sechsten jahrhundert wurde
es als christliche kirche erbaut doch im
fünfzehnten jahrhundert erobern die
osmanen die stadt und nutzen das gebäude
fortan als moschee die minarette werden
gebaut
nach ende des osmanischen reiches wurde
die hagia sophia vor 85 jahren ein
museum jetzt so will es präsident
erdogan könnte sich das wieder ändern
katrin eigendorf
sie feiern eine international höchst
umstrittene entscheidung allah ist groß
rufen die die sich spontan vor der hagia
sophia versammelt haben
self eis gehen vom sultan ahmed platz in
die welt und das türkische fernsehen
baut für sondersendungen auf die
nachricht in der hagia sophia dürfen
muslime wieder beten
ich habe mich ehrlich gesagt jetzt
gefreut das ist jetzt zu seiner
richtigen strecke wieder zurück
umgewandelt ist und wenn es morgen
wirklich zum zu einem gebet kommen
sollte innen drin da würde ich auch
selber mal teilhaben wollen und diese
diese situation auch selber genießen
wollen es ist geworden was es vorher war
und jetzt dürfen wir ohne ticket rhein
ein einseitiger blick auf die geschichte
gebaut wurde die hagia sophia als kirche
1000 jahre beteten hier christen bis
daraus eine moschee wurde als museum ist
der bau seit 1934 offen für alle
doch damit ist jetzt schluss richter des
obersten verwaltungsgerichts haben heute
die umwandlung zum museum für ungültig
erklärt die hagia sophia wird von
erdogan gerne in szene gesetzt als
symbol osmanischer eroberung das kommt
an bei nationalisten und religiösen per
twitter veröffentlichte erdogan heute
ein dokument wonach die hagia sophia ab
sofort wieder für gebete genutzt werden
darf eine entscheidung die christen
weltweit kritisieren aber das spielt
heute in istanbul keine rolle
zurück nach deutschland der
zdf-fernsehrat soll die vielfalt der
gesellschaft abbilden und programme und
onlineangebote des zdf im auge behalten
heute hat er wichtige entscheidungen
getroffen auch solche die sie als
zuschauer unmittelbar betreffen denn
künftig gibt es in der mediathek noch
mehr inhalte und neue online angebote
für jüngere zuschauer
susanne gelhard und julia schröter
berichten
[Musik]
ob drama serie über partnerschaft in
corona zeiten oder eine doku über den
kampf um gute lebensmittel die zdf
mediathek ist ein angebot für alle
nun soll sie noch stärker jüngere nutzer
ansprechen auch mit neuen formaten die
speziell fürs netz konzipiert sind für
seine programme und plattformen hat das
zdf unter neuen gesetzlichen vorgaben
ein sogenanntes telemedienkonzept
entwickelt das dem gebührenzahler mehr
bietet das angebot insgesamt soll größer
werden inhalte können länger im netz
angeschaut werden und es sollen mehr
online produkte für jüngere produziert
werden
auch zum beispiel für social media
plattformen und youtube der
zdf-fernsehrat der die einhaltung der
sender richtlinien überwacht hat das
neue telemedienkonzept heute genehmigt
die beratungen corona bedingt in der
rheingoldhalle in mainz mit viel abstand
der wiedergewählten vorsitzenden mal
intime geht es vor allem darum den
öffentlich rechtlichen auftrag auch im
netz gut zu erfüllen
der medienmarkt wird sich in dieser
digitalisierung weiter entwickeln
und da das zdf zu befähigen zu ermuntern
anzuregen aber auch zu bewerten wie es
in diesem wettbewerbsumfeld sich weiter
verhält das ist die eine der wichtigen
aufgaben und glaubwürdige inhalte
attraktiv auch für jüngere die neue zdf
heute app hat schon den anfang gemacht
da ist heute das finalturnier in
lissabon ausgelöst worden
ein unbequemer gegner im viertelfinale
für rb leipzig die spielen gegen
atletico madrid und die bayern schauen
wir mal
denn die müssen ja noch auf ihrer jagd
nach dem triple erstmal ins achtelfinal
rückspiel nach dem souveränen 13 0 im
hinspiel spricht vieles dafür dass die
bayern sich gegen chelsea am 8 august
durchsetzen als viertelfinal gegner
wartet dann der sieger des duells
barcelona neapel hinspielergebnis dort
eins zu eins bei leipzig hingegen steht
der gegner bereits fest atlético madrid
der finalist von 2016
rasenballsport muss im viertelfinale
allerdings auf timo werner verzichten
der spielt mittlerweile beim fc chelsea
darf aber für seinen neuen club gegen
die bayern noch nicht antreten
auch das europa league final turnier
wurde heute ausgelost das findet ihr in
nordrhein-westfalen statt die drei
deutschen clubs die müssen vorher zuvor
noch ihre achtelfinal rückspiele
absolvieren der sieger aus dem duell don
jetzt gegen wolfsburg trifft auf den
sieger basel gegen frankfurt da kannst
also ein deutsches finale ein deutsches
viertelfinale geben
und der sieger aus leverkusen gegen
glasgow rangers trifft auf inter mailand
oder raid affe heute auch verkündet
erstens der start der neuen fußball
bundesliga saison ist der 18 september
und zweitens florian kufeld bleibt
trainer des beinahe absteigers bremen er
soll werde auch in der nächsten saison
zusammen mit geschäftsführer frank
baumann sportlich anführen
ja morgen abend letzte entscheidung in
der fußball bundesliga relegation
drittligist ingolstadt muss nach der 0 2
hinspielpleite gegen zweitligist
nürnberg alles geben und auf einen
gegenspieler besonders aufpassen
fabian nürnberger gebürtige hamburger
aber auf dem platz ein nürnberger mit
zwei treffern hat sich der 20-jährige im
hinspiel lustige wortspiele beschert und
seinem team eine gute ausgangsposition
wenn ihr euch natürlich auch super happy
dass wir eine nürnberger haben der in
nürnberg bei so einem wichtigen spiel
zwei tore schießt also dafür aber gerne
am samstag in ingolstadt machen totale
überlegenheit beim 2 0 erfolg für den
klub trotzdem will das nürnberger
trainer team mit michael wiesinger und
marek mintal die konzentration fürs
rückspiel in ingolstadt hochhalten
vielleicht schlägt ja auch die nächste
große stunde von fabian nürnberger und
das spiel live zu sehen uns im zdf ab 18
uhr das wetter ist nicht wirklich
urlauber freundlich morgen gibt es
dauerregen an den alpen sonst wechseln
sonne und wolken die details hat gleich
gunther tiersch marietta slomka freut
sich auf sie um 10 und heute schon mal
und wir freuen uns wenn sie morgen in
der halbzeitpause interesse an
nachrichten haben machen sie sich noch
einen schönen freitagabend auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend liebe zuschauer an den alpen
geht es jetzt rund erst die schweren
gewitter und dann der dauerregen ein
wetterumschwung ist in gange kühle luft
von der nordsee hat uns bereits erreicht
heute in norddeutschland nur 12 13 grad
und diese luft dringt weiter vor trifft
hier über den alpen auf die schwül-heiße
luft es entstehen diese gewitter und
dann der dauerregen und der hält eben
morgen den ganzen tag über an aber das
hoch von westen das bringt uns in den
nächsten tagen wieder freundliches
wetter in den nächsten stunden also noch
zum teil heftige gewitter mit sturmböen
hagel und auch mit starkregen de zieht
dann über bayern langsam nach osten
danach setzt der dauerregen ein
und an den küsten kann es nochmal
schauer geben morgen ist es dann ganz
freundlich es wechseln sonne und wolken
in norddeutschland ab und zu gibt es ein
paar regenschauer im nordwesten vor
allen dingen die ziehen so ein bisschen
ins landesinnere und es wird dieser
starke westwind dazu auch in der mitte
ist es trocken manchmal stärker bewölkt
und dann südlich der donau dauerregen
erst einmal zum nachmittag zieht er sich
mehr und mehr zu den alpen zurück die
temperaturen dann in dem dauerregen nur
16 grad sonst bis zu 24 im südwesten und
in norddeutschland 17 bis 20 grad ja die
aussichten sehen freundlich aus es wird
immer sonniger und langsam auch bis
dienstag immer wärmer ich wünsche ihnen
einen schönen abend und machen sie's gut